[Music]
[Music]
Gertler is considered the rolls-royce of
a cigar industry you do not make
millions and millions of cigars what we
do make is the finest quality cigars
that are out there
my name is paisa and Sonia I'm the owner
and CEO of Gurkha cigars I'm smoking the
Gurkha HMR HMR stands for His Majesty's
reserve the world's most expensive cigar
the Box sells for $25,000 and there'll
be a small increase by next year of
$30,000 the cigars are close two
thousand dollars each we hunt for the
most exotic tobacco's around the world
in 1996 we got a hold of 18-year old
tobacco and we fermented it with fluid
the 13 cognac the best cognac in the
world con yang basically not only
smoothes out the cigar but it gives that
aroma when you take it out of the glass
cube we initially started off with 75
boxes per year and now we're down to
about 20 boxes per year most of them are
completely sold out we have a three year
waiting list on these cigars people like
to collect our products they keep them
for their value and then they resell
them we have captains of the industry
when they want to celebrate a very big
deal a lot of dignitaries a lot of royal
families Bill Clinton loves the beauties
he loves the Gurkhas Matthew McConaughy
people try to copy us a lot but we have
no competition
we tell everybody please smoke a Cuban
cigar and then smoked our cigars and
once they smoke a Cuban and then once a
smoke a Gurkha or they smoke a cigar
from Dominican Republic they realize
what a difference in quality it is it's
a very unique smell very unique flavor
completely different than anything you
have ever smoked in your life so if you
ever have the pleasure of smoking one
you will understand the difference in
the taste of four normal cigar to an HM
are you're working on something right to
them that's going to take another three
to four years you're still working on
the tobacco aging it at the present time
we should have something close to the
HMR once they finish
[Music]
you